[Music]
on this monday night russian forces hit
a safe haven the deadly barrage raining
down on levive
and fears russia has captured canadians
plus new video of putin's prized warship
sinking
keeping the faith there was a time in
which being religious has certain social
benefits why more canadians are losing
their religion hope floats for a stuck
container ship this vessel had basically
plowed itself
fully aground the ever forward finally
living up to its name again and
unbearably funny it's wrestlemania the
wild spectacle brewing in the backyard
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas
good evening and thanks for joining us
tonight the human toll is growing as
russia intensifies air attacks in the
territory it seeks to control and a
warning some of the images in our
coverage you might find hard to watch
russia is now targeting cities further
west like leve that have until now
largely escaped the death and
destruction witnessed elsewhere like
mass graves found further east along the
front lines of this war
ukraine is also accusing russia of
carpet bombing mariupol an attempt to
crush that city's fighting spirit and
late today ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky confirmed russian forces have
begun a new offensive in the donbass
region redmond shannon has our top story
tonight
ukraine's western city of la viv has
been a relative safe haven during almost
two months of fighting until now russian
missiles killing at least seven people
local authorities say the deadly advance
of russia's war extending to a city
that's become a refuge for thousands
fleeing it's also a major supply hub
this building was once a tire shop
warehouses hit two russia claims they
were military targets
according to this video published by the
mayor of levive one of the injured was a
three-year-old boy who lost part of a
finger
more attacks and deaths in the city of
harkev2 russia boasting it hit 315
military targets across ukraine
these victims appear to be civilians
where are we supposed to evacuate to now
says this woman they are hitting all of
ukraine an increasing feeling that
nowhere is truly safe
many of those who remain in ukraine are
preparing for a major escalation from
russian forces during the last two or
three days it were
every day one or two rockets flying to
kramatos
i think the russians are
targeting
military hardware depots factories and
trying to erode and reduce the
capability of the ukrainian armed forces
to resist their strike when it comes in
the east
the remaining ukrainian forces holed up
at that steel plant in mariupol vow to
drain russian resources as long as they
can
in moscow monday russian president
vladimir putin called the international
sanctions an economic blitzkrieg that
has backfired by increasing inflation in
the west meanwhile his ukrainian
counterpart vladimir zelinski submitted
more documents to the european union as
part of the long process to join the
bloc the
saying that his peoples souls and minds
are already part of europe anyway
redmond shannon double news london
russia's new offensive could effectively
landlock
tonight the area russian forces control
has grown significantly as fighting
rages in strategic cities across
southern and eastern ukraine including
mikolayev and mariupol moscow claims to
be in full control of the port city
except for one small pocket around the
azov stall steel works where ukrainian
soldiers from the azov battalion are
still holding out but are completely
surrounded as abigail beeman explains
there are reports canadians are also
there holed up inside
explosions thunder and smoke rises from
the azostal steel plant one of the
biggest metallurgical plants in europe a
warren of buildings and tunnels where
ukrainian forces are holed up as russia
tries to take full control of mariupol
russia's defense ministry says according
to ukrainians who surrendered there are
up to 400 foreign fighters inside
including canadians that has not been
verified but analysts say it's plausible
we've seen pretty clear evidence that
canadians in pretty in sizable numbers
have taken steps to
join the fight in ukraine
the ukrainian government has gone out of
its way to make that easier canada has
advised against all travel to ukraine
russia has labeled those foreign
fighters mercenaries meaning they would
not be entitled to the protections of
the geneva convention if captured it is
scary because the mercenary line would
give russia
some
ability to do things to those people
those presumed canadians that they
wouldn't be able to do to normal pows
walter dorn disputes russia's position
saying canadians fighting are under the
command and control of ukraine and says
if there are canadians captured in as of
stall they may become bargaining chips
in some kind of prisoner swap similar to
these two british pows obviously i'd
really appreciate your help in this
matter they appeared on russian state tv
monday captured in mario poll asking
boris johnson to exchange them for an
ally of putin with a similar plea it's
not clear whether any of the men were
speaking freely it's also unclear how
many civilians may be inside the steel
plant
this video shared on a twitter account
called canadian ukrainian volunteer
claims that alice is inside the plant
her mom an army medic tending the
wounded neither global affairs canada
nor the foreign affairs minister's
office would confirm whether any
canadians are in is azoff stall saying
they don't have a record of canadians
who choose to travel but the department
did tell global news they haven't had
any calls for help from any canadians
inside the plant noting they may not be
able to help canadians who are injured
or captured by russian forces abigail
beeman global news ottawa
we're getting our first glimpse of
russia's flagship missile carrier just
moments before it sank a short video and
images yet to be verified independently
have been posted online and reportedly
show the russian destroyer moskva
billowing smoke and listing russia
claims the ship capsized during a storm
after a fire broke out on board but
ukraine insists it struck the moskva in
a missile attack
in less than a week french voters will
cast their ballots in a key election
that could have major implications for
how the west handles russia france's
incumbent leader emmanuel macron is in a
tight race against far-right politician
marine le pen
macron has been a major player in trying
to de-escalate the conflict in ukraine
while le pen is seen by many as an ally
of russian president vladimir putin eric
sorenson reports
the race for the presidency of france is
too close for comfort for emmanuel
macron and for many in the west who fear
what will happen if he loses madame le
pen
finney with marine le pen it's finished
says macron when it comes to foreign
investment
but it's also he says a referendum on
europe and whether france will turn hard
right macron has used the world stage to
bolster france's support for nato and
for weeks has tried to persuade russia's
vladimir putin to stop the war in
ukraine
marine le pen the far-right candidate
has made it clear she would weaken ties
to the european union and to nato and
forge closer links to russia
she favors what she calls a
rapprochement between nato and russia no
one would be happier than putin with a
le pen victory of the french presidency
so it would be
very very serious for the the
nato and western support for
ukraine le pen has toned down her
established views on race in this
campaign appealing to voters on issues
like the cost of living
i have the people behind me she says the
first vote a week ago gave a narrow win
to macron over le pen but together they
won just half the votes left-wing
candidate jean-luc melanchol finished a
close third but where will his and other
votes go now
melanchon told his voters not a single
vote to marine le pen
but he did not endorse macron and many
voters simply want change
i'm against everything the president
stands for he's a bully she says
but would you rather a woman financed by
vladimir putin says a young man the
first time they squared off in 2017
macron earned two-thirds of all votes
against le pen but this time looks
closer one projection puts macron's
margin at
54-46 ahead of this week's election
she's benefiting from classic support
for populism but populism might not be
enough this year when war is on europe's
doorstep emmanuel macron has benefited
really from the rally around the flag
effect because of the ukraine war in the
end macron may prevail not because
voters are eager to re-elect him but may
want to stop le pen eric sorensen global
news toronto
as canadians wrap up the easter long
weekend and recognize other religious
events new data suggests religion is
becoming less important to people a new
angus read poll shows 18 percent of
canadians identify as religiously
committed faith is strongest across the
prairies while quebecers are now the
least religious as mike relay reports
the survey shows many canadians now
believe that some religions are more
damaging than beneficial to society
religious services aren't as crowded as
they were a few decades ago while
religion still plays a large role in
many canadian households and wider
society its overall influence is waning
i think just in general we are becoming
a more secularized country so much of it
has to do as well with um the way we're
raised it has to do with with
generational change a new survey
conducted by angus reid in partnership
with the christian think tank curtis
found that while 19 percent of canadians
now consider themselves non-believers
more canadians than ever identify as
spiritually uncertain and i think that
speaks to you know the social benefits
or the social respectability of religion
there was a time in which being
religious had certain social benefits if
you were applying for a job there was an
assumption that that was a merit that
was a good thing
those things aren't as real anymore but
it's more than that just over a third of
canadians now say they pray once or
twice a month while almost as many say
they feel the good of religion in
society outweighs the bad
the broader society still is
not
fully comfortable and and fully clear
about what to do with religion and
therefore they
they show some signs of discomfort at
least maybe it's not intolerance at the
at the moment it is discomfort hinduism
sikhism and judaism are widely seen in a
positive light
father god i just thank you but the
respondents to this survey don't share
the same views about evangelical
christianity in islam and to a lesser
extent catholicism which a small
majority of participants here said they
considered to be more damaging than
beneficial to society
rekhimstra of the evangelical fellowship
of canada believes that's in small part
because of how they're portrayed in
american media
you know i watch netflix just like
everybody else and and
and really when you see the perceptions
of evangelicals or or christians or
religious people generally let's just
say devout religious people
they are usually presented as deviants
and perhaps it is matters of perception
that are pushing canadians to both sides
of the spiritual spectrum leaving a
growing middle that largely avoids
traditional religious labels
mike drolite global news toronto
and you can read about how immigration
is sustaining religion in canada on our
website global news dot ca slash global
national
nova scotians are marking the second
anniversary of one of canada's worst
mass shootings by remembering the 22
people who died
bagpipes and quiet moments of reflection
marked two years since a gunman
disguised as an rcmp officer went on a
killing spree over 13 hours across the
province flags were lowered across nova
scotia today the province is planning to
designate april 18th and 19th as
official days of remembrance starting
next year
and it was a deadly easter weekend
across the u.s after three mass
shootings there two teenagers died and
several others were injured at a house
party in pittsburgh yesterday police say
as many as 50 rounds were fired inside
the airbnb rental property investigators
believe multiple shooters were involved
and in south carolina two major
shootings at a nightclub and a mall left
more than 18 people injured
the push to better protect teenagers
from violence coming up the recent
tragedies and who's most vulnerable
[Music]
students at an edmonton high school are
mourning the tragic death of one of
their peers karen versaholda died friday
after being stabbed earlier this month
it's the fourth death in six months
involving canadian students being
attacked at or near their schools and as
heather yorick's west explains advocates
are pushing for action
a memorial is growing outside edmonton's
mcnally high school as the community
grieves the loss of a friend and peer
our hearts are certainly with them
with our mcnally school community
with our students our staff
and everyone impacted
by what is really the unimaginable in
the last six months alone there have
been several violent incidents at or
near canadian schools last november
fifteen-year-old mahir dasani was
fatally stabbed in toronto four months
later eighteen-year-old jaheem robinson
was shot and killed at school in what
police say was a targeted attack
lucas godette 16 and in grade 10 was
fatally stabbed in montreal in february
2. and there was a second montreal teen
stabbed outside their school this month
the victim there survived but
sixteen-year-old karanvir sahota wasn't
so lucky he died friday days after being
stabbed outside his edmonton high school
clearly there's a lot of issues going on
and we're not addressing them the
executive director of youth mental
health canada says the pandemic has made
problems of mental health youth suicide
and youth violence more severe and not
enough is being done to support kids we
don't respond with immediacy or efficacy
when young people are in crisis in a
health crisis we put people on a wait
list statistics show young racialized
men are particularly vulnerable we
really need to be attending to the way
kids get along with each other bullying
rates are really high in canada they're
among the highest of economically
advanced countries in the world canada's
research chair on school-based violence
prevention says schools are still not
doing enough to tackle the country's
bullying problem
after two years of collective trauma the
need for social and emotional
developmental support is perhaps needed
more now than ever before heather yorks
west global news calgary
shanghai confirms its first deaths
linked to china's biggest covet outbreak
since the virus was first discovered all
three people were elderly and had
underlying health conditions and were
not vaccinated shanghai china's
financial hub is now entering another
round of mass testing to help curb the
spread most of the city's 25 million
residents are also being confined to
their homes for a third straight week
despite the easing of other public
health measures still ahead violent
clashes in sweden what sparked the
chaotic demonstrations next
[Music]
at least 40 people have been injured in
riots that spread throughout sweden over
the easter weekend protesters are angry
a danish far-right politician with
swedish roots burned a koran during a
tour of the country 20 police vehicles
have been damaged or destroyed and more
than two dozen people arrested police
are calling the riots extremely serious
crimes against society and they believe
some protesters might have links to
criminal gangs that target police
internationally
israeli troops shot and wounded two
palestinians in violent clashes that
erupted during an arrest raid in the
occupied west bank
the israeli military says 11
palestinians were arrested during the
overnight raids following days of unrest
at the al-aqsa mosque
tensions are high after the first
weekend of ramadan and passover saw
dozens of palestinians injured after
they hurled stones and fireworks at
police officers who fired back with
rubber bullets and stun grenades
up next the ever forward floats again
what it took to get this mammoth
container ship unstuck from the mud
[Music]
the race is on to prevent an
environmental disaster off the coast of
tunisia after a tanker carrying 750
metric tons of diesel fuel sank the ship
was heading from egypt to malto when it
hit bad weather and sank on saturday no
leaks have been detected so far and all
seven crew members were rescued a
protective boom has been placed around
the site to help contain any fuel slick
and italy says it's sending a navy
vessel specializing in marine disasters
to help out
an oversized rescue mission has
successfully ended on the east coast of
the u.s where a massive cargo ship ran
aground about five weeks ago contrary to
its name the ever forward wasn't going
anywhere it had been stuck in the mud
until it was finally freed on the
weekend but as jackson proskow reports
the saga doesn't end there
the ever forward is once again moving
forward no small feat for a ship that
spent more than a month stuck in deep
trouble so just how stuck was the ship
the ship was stuck this vessel had
basically plowed itself
fully aground and it went about a ship
length and a half
out of the channel as problems go this
was a big one
a cargo ship the length of three
football fields weighing more than the
cn tower wedged in the muddy bottom of
the chesapeake bay if you've ever been
in a marsh and you've stepped in the
marsh with your boot and then you try to
pull it out and your foot comes out but
not the boot kind of the same thing on a
grander scale it all started in march
when the ever forward missed a turn and
ran aground in shallow water for 36 days
she was beached they tried pushing and
pulling with tugboats they tried
dredging around the hull
it started to feel like the ever forward
might be stuck forever
it's not unlike what happened to the
ever given a sister ship of the ever
forward that became wedged in the suez
canal last year it took six days and a
lot of digging to set her free
weeks after getting stuck the ever
forward needed some forward thinking
crews made the risky decision to remove
about 500 of her 5 000 containers at sea
to lighten the load
high hopes and high tide set the boat
back afloat they have to survey the
vessel to determine the amount of damage
done to it it's been sitting on the
bottom for five weeks even if the vessel
is found to be in ship shape the fate of
her containers is now about as clear as
the mud she was stuck in
maritime law allows the shipping company
to charge its customers for some of the
cost of saving the vessel
the ever forward may be free
her cargo could stay stuck in the courts
for months
jackson prosko global news washington
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm chris galas and we'll
leave you tonight with some wildlife
wrestling
oh oh now they're both in there it's
wrestlemania
young black bears emerged from
hibernation to duke it out in a bc
backyard trampoline luckily for the
owners it remained undamaged once the
two animals bounced off probably to
continue their cage match somewhere else
hope you enjoyed that thanks very much
for watching donna friesen we'll be back
with you tomorrow hope you have a great
evening
[Applause]
[Music]